but let's move let's move on to talk
about why we fight uh because what you
talk about in the book is a much broader
look at conflict and why human beings
engage in warfare and conflict more
generally
why do we fight
why do we engage in conflict
so
humans have evolved like every other
animal on the planet right we are part
of the animal kingdom and
we've evolved to um increase our chances
of surviving and
reproducing all right this is kind of
standard stuff
and so the question you have to answer
when people are fighting wars is what's
the evolutionary advantage of fighting
wars because there's a huge death rate
and huge death rates i mean let me give
you an example of how big the death
threats are in the first world war
the french
the cohort of french men that fought so
say 16 to about 35
a third of them died
[Music]
a third
that is
that in any other world would be known
as a negative selection pressure yeah
okay so why does war exist and actually
that death rate is is probably compared
favorably to what the death rates were
like from conflict in say the stone age
even higher
and so what you've got to do is look for
mechanisms
that humans have that drive them to do
things that are of an evolutionary
advantage but then
unfortunately also
result in war and there are two really
obvious contenders one of them is the
pursuit of social status and the other
one is this need to belong
and the pursuit of social status
particularly for men has a huge
evolutionary advantage
humans have been
you know we're mostly monogamous now but
actually in our history
there was much much much more polygamy
and so good old days as i like to call
it
[Laughter]
vote as a social conservative yeah
absolutely and therefore they don't
believe in uh polygamy yeah anyway carry
on sorry we'll ignore your prejudice
your bigotry against social concern you
you are a gambler yes
that's absolutely clear a wee little
gammon um so
yeah
think about think about polygamy like
this okay
if the
because the higher up the social
rank you get as a man
this is the pecking order the more
action you get the more action you get
and the more children you have so if the
top 50 of men have two wives the bottom
50 percent have none yeah so there's a
massive evolutionary selection pressure
to get in that so we have jeffrey miller
the evolutionary psychologist on the
show making precisely this point right
yeah so so the competition for social
status essentially for men in an
evolution rate it's actually worth it
even if there's a
30 chance of being killed exactly
because the the the bounty that you get
potentially at least is so great
evolution
can never tell us
what effect will it have on that
individual yeah well evolution tells us
is across thousands of generations
and across millions of people what the
averages will be
and if say the average death rate from
war because of the drive towards social
status and i'm plucking these figures
out there but just to give an example
you know if the death rate is three out
of ten from war
but the advantages of that same
mechanism that drives social status as a
four out of ten then that mechanism will
remain in the gene pool yes
yeah and it's the same with belonging
right
there's a huge that was the most
interesting part of the book because i
think most people will be aware of the
first thing that we've talked about but
the idea that people fight and are
prepared to go to war and be killed and
maimed
in order to belong to some kind of tribe
it's fascinating to me tell us more
about that so whilst well social status
is a positive thing you're trying to
attain you know the higher you have your
social status the more as you said the
more action you get right
but belonging is actually the opposite
so you've got to think back to
where humans did most of their cognitive
evolution which was on
the african savanna basically between
about 80 and 50 000 years ago
there was a huge burst of cognitive
evolution and about 50 000 years ago we
have was called the cultural explosion
so artwork and all that stuff starts to
appear
and
in that environment humans lived in
groups of less than 30.
kinship related
maybe a few non-kin members but that was
the that was the group right and these
bands were fighting each other and they
were surviving in the environment that
had lots of wild animals
and in that environment um
not having a social group to belong to
was an almost immediate death sentence
okay
and so these feelings that we have
towards belonging to something whether
it's a tribe
a you know chieftain an ancient empire a
modern nation state a political party a
football team a choir these all
triggered by the same mechanism which
forces us to seek out a social group
it's something to belong to
and and we do that you know as i said
because to not have a social group in in
evolutionary terms and don't forget
we're still stuck now in 2020 with these
mechanisms
um that we evolved that we've evolved
over the last you know two million years
as hominids to not to not belong
and was a death sentence
and if you look at how that mechanism
evolved it it gives you a real insight
into both politics and war
so think about it this way
if you have this mechanism which causes
you to seek belonging yeah to find
people to um
come together to co-join with
that only works if as well as creating a
drive towards an in-group if it creates
an out group at the same time you can't
have one without the other and why well
because if if the mechanism evolved that
said trust everyone pull everyone
towards you make everyone part of your
group then
another genotype would arise in the
population that said take advantage of
those people who are trusting all the
time so the only way you can have a
mechanism that says trust other people
is if you say trust the in group and
don't trust the out group
and this mechanism which you know has a
hormonal pathway which is regulated by a
hormone called oxytocin and status is
regulated by testosterone but this
hormonal pathway
um does two things it creates feelings
of empathy and trust within the in-group
at the same time that it create that it
derogatizes and out-group and creates
distrust and what you know it has all
sorts of other effects like you can see
heterogeneity within the in-group but
you you homogenize the out group what we
might call othering in social science
yeah you know these are very basic
um
mostly subconscious evolutionary
mechanisms that we've evolved for very
good reasons
both status and belonging but that have
the side effects of
driving us towards group conflict it's a
fascinating explanation of why francis
is racist
[Music]